Oh why's everybody so upset about these
guys there's no denying that you're a
great actor Joaquin Phoenix you've
proven it over and over and the Joker
was just an incredible film but we have
to talk about that whole Golden Globes
acceptance speech
it went from funny to bizarre really
quickly and we're not quite sure why but
you managed to insult basically everyone
including yourself it was definitely one
of the most interesting award show
speeches that we've ever seen when
celebrities accept awards they go
onstage unscripted and things can get
awkward award shows have a long history
of celebrities criticizing other people
governments and institutions check out
these ten times that celebs used their
acceptance speeches to throw shade let
us not take this planet for granted I do
not take tonight for granted thank you
so much there is no denying that Taylor
Swift is a success she's won a ton of
awards for her singing and songwriting
and she's also developed a bit of a
reputation through throwing shade she's
been in countless Twitter feuds
she writes songs about her exes and she
has thrown shade in her acceptance
speeches more than once but the best
moment comes when she got her revenge
with some clever and inspirational shade
in 2009 Taylor won the Video Music Award
for video of the year Kanye West
interrupted her speech to talk about how
Beyonce deserved the award instead I'm
happy for you I'm let you finish but
Beyonce had one of the best videos of
all time it was uncomfortable for
everyone later Kanye went on to suggest
that he was responsible for Taylor's
success he even wrote a song about it
when Taylor accepted her second Grammy
for album of the year she clapped back
in 2016
she noted that she was the first woman
to win that award twice she told all the
girls listening that there will be
people who try to undercut and take
credit for their accomplishments but she
told them not to listen to those people
and keep working hard Taylor knows
better than anyone that haters are going
to hate hate hate or take credit for
your accomplishments
this next acceptance speech was a joint
effort by two a list celebrities Brad
Pitt won the award for Best Supporting
Actor at the 2020 British Academy Film &
Television Awards Brad couldn't make it
to the baptists so he had his co-star
from Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
deliver his speech instead as she read
the speech margot robbie threw shade at
all of britain brad speech called them
out for brexit since britain is no
longer part of the european union
welcome to the club
he said he hoped they got the better end
of the divorce settlement that sure
sounds like he was also throwing shade
at his ex-wife Angelina Jolie Margot
then said that Brad is going to name the
award Harry because he's excited to
bring it back to the States
they were referencing Prince Harry's
decision to step down from the royal
family we aren't quite sure how William
and Kate who were in the audience felt
about that comment that he is gonna name
this Harry cuz he is really excited
about bringing it back to the States
the Grammys are considered the most
prestigious musical war for many artists
getting a Grammy is the ultimate dream
and that used to be the dream for Halsey
to the pop rock icon has become hugely
successful
she keeps topping the charts and fans
love her she had a wildly successful
year in 2019
many of the music award shows have
recognized her success but when the
Grammy nominations were announced this
year Halsey was notably absent how could
the Grammys disagree so much with bands
and other award shows
well Halsey won an American Music Award
and used that time to call out the
Grammys she said she used to believe
that awards like that were the ultimate
validation but she's older and wiser and
she knows that's not the case she said
that it's the fans who made her
successful she thanked the AMAs for
giving her fans a voice because they are
who really matter her speech was a hit
but we have a feeling this won't be the
last time she's a snubbed for a Grammy
okay Zayn Malik became famous because of
his run with one direction but he's made
it clear over the years that he's not
really happy about it
Zayn has thrown a lot of shade at his
former band he called their music
generic
and made waves when he chose to go solo
he made it clear that he always wanted
to leave and do his own thing he wanted
to do something fresh
he's commented on his former bandmates
and aired their dirty laundry in
interviews he's found success on his own
but he's still bitter about his past
plenty of people still associate him
with one direction it can be hard to go
solo but Zane has done really well for
himself in 2016 Zane won an American
Music Award for Best New Artist when he
got on stage but the first thing he said
was this one's just got my name on it
right yikes
he was clapping back at One Direction
and pointing out that he earned the
award by himself celebrities have often
used their award speeches to make
political statements celebrities have a
unique privilege to have millions of
people listening to what they have to
say when they get the chance to speak
out many of them take it Meryl Streep is
one example the Academy Award winning
actor is a Hollywood icon she's one of
the most respected women in the business
in 2017 she was given the Cecil B
deMille Award for lifetime achievement
at the Golden Globes and she has
achieved a lot Meryl made a political
statement about the US president making
fun of a disabled reporter she praised
the Hollywood Foreign Press for their
work and for being some of the most
hated people in American society it was
a classy speech she didn't even use the
president's name she called his display
a performance and noted that it made his
chosen audience laugh she noted that
humiliation and violence only incite
more violence and she encouraged the
press to do their job with honor no
matter what keep watching for more
moments when acceptance speeches got
political imitated a disabled reporter
someone he outranked
calling out the president in acceptance
speeches isn't new one of the most
famous Oscar moments happened in 2003
Michael Moore is a famous documentary
filmmaker he addresses controversial
issues and he's got a reputation for
making controversial statements at the
2003 Academy Awards Michael won Best
Documentary for Bowling for Columbine he
went on a long political tirade and it
was not well-received
he criticized a George Bush who was
president of the u.s. at the time he
called him a fictional president for
both his foreign and domestic policy
Michael was booed by many members of the
audience it was wartime in the US and
many people felt that he was being
unpatriotic but others supported his
stance no matter your opinion there's no
denying that this is one of the most
memorable acceptance speeches in history
it was definitely
most controversial Michael was shunned
for a while but continues to make
documentaries we live in the time where
we have fictitious of election results
that Alexa fictitious president
political acceptance speeches don't
always involve calling out the president
sometimes they involve throwing shade at
whole groups of regular citizens that's
exactly what happened in Sean Penn's
Oscar speech in 2009 Sean won Best Actor
for his role as Harvey Milk in milk
Harvey Milk was an activist and he was
the first openly gay politician in
California milk came out about the time
that proposition 8 was being voted on
this is our lives who I'm fighting for
if proposition 8 had passed it would
have banned same gender marriage in
California Sean Penn had become a loud
voice against the measure because of his
time filming milk in his speech he
called out everyone who had voted for
Prop 8 he told them to sit and reflect
on their shame from being on the wrong
side of history he got a lot of flack
for this many people who had been fans
of Sean felt offended by his speech
ultimately prop 8 did not pass in
California but plenty of celebrities
made waves with their public statements
we've got to have equal rights for
everyone we are kicking it old school
for this next acceptance speech The
Godfather is one of the most iconic
films ever made it's a Hollywood legend
Marlon Brando played the main character
Don Vito Corleone Marlon was already a
highly successful actor he was also
known as an activist for civil rights in
1973 Marlon won best actor for the
Godfather but something shocking
happened he sent a Native American
activist and actress Sacheen
Littlefeather on stage instead she
refused to take the award
she said that Marlon wanted her to go up
and refuse the award on his behalf he
was criticizing Hollywood for the way
they treated Native Americans movies at
that time usually portrayed Native
Americans in a very negative and
inaccurate way it was also really
difficult to find success as a Native
American actor Marlon was highly
criticized for this done and Sachi ins
career suffered she was blacklisted from
roles in Hollywood very regretfully
cannot accept this very generous
not everything is political and who
better to remind us of that then Nicki
Minaj in 2015
Nicki Minaj and Taylor Swift got into a
Twitter few Nicki had been nominated for
three VMAs
but she wasn't nominated for video of
the year
like so many Twitter feuds it turned
ugly really quick but Taylor isn't the
person that Nicki threw shade at in her
speech at the VMAs Nicki and Taylor bury
the hatchet Taylor admitted that she had
misunderstood Nicki's intent in her
original tweet but in the middle of this
Miley Cyrus got involved we all do
interviews and we all know how they
manipulate she said that Nicki is not a
nice person she also criticized Nicki
for her comments on racial bias Miley
was hosting the VMAs and Nicki won the
award for best hip-hop video
she called Miley a name then coined the
famous line what's good
that clap Bach had the Internet in an
uproar what's good became the best way
to throw shade that year Miley what's
good
Joaquin Phoenix won Best Actor for his
role in the Joker at the 2020 Golden
Globes his acceptance speech managed to
make several political statements throw
shade at lots of people and get censored
he dropped a lot of f-bombs that had to
be muted over the broadcast he threw
shade at all award shows by saying that
there's no Best Actor we all know
there's no competition between us he
made comments on ethical veganism and
the importance of voting then he threw
shade at his fellow actors he called
them out on their lack of action in
important matters but in a bizarre turn
of events Joaquin even threw shade out
himself he called himself a pretty
vulgar term and said he wasn't always a
virtuous man he said he didn't
understand how Hollywood puts up with
them he held nothing back in his
acceptance speech which actors do you
think will drop shade at the next award
show let us know in the comments thanks
for watching give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more great videos see you next time
[Music]